[Music]
what's up guys just sign some books
you're about to watch the session we
just had I'll be honest with you there's
a lot of pressure on Jason I think
there's at least four viral individual
clips this is probably the long-form one
but Jason I'm not joking around [ __ ]
find them believe this or not because in
the garyvee land there's one kind of
perception but in my corporate land I
massively underestimated by our clients
at vaynermedia because I don't look the
part because I don't have this degree or
that I use it my advantage but I have a
big difference than you I own my
business but on the client side I still
have to sell them and sometimes I use
the under estimating as an advantage
sometimes when I know I'm being honest
underestimated I come into a room
I'll go hard on depth and stake just to
make them realize what's actually going
on here like sometimes I'll mm-hmm
sometimes I'll might drop not from like
pontificating and like sizzle like big
profound statement me I'll go into some
real [ __ ] hardcore detail real fast
about business then makes them real
uncomfortable because I might know their
business better to the name of their
business when you're being
underestimated speak facts by asking
straight up a hundred percent and just
knowing back to the same game I told him
people Gary I hit up I deemed all the
influencers like you told me nobody
responded I'm like how many they're like
130 I'm like good there's about nine
million more no because that's not the
way to position it right because most
people want answer that because somebody
who's got an audience that's all they
see I would say how can I help you you
see where I'm going like like yo I [ __ ]
with you like how can I help you yes you
do you of your time you never know
d-roc didn't have any leverage do you
rock asked me four times and then
finally said yep fine make me a [ __ ]
video not even that mindset and then
this all happened because of it that's
real that's real
the story that's the story he has to be
four times I want to make a video for
you he was a video that I wasn't making
content like that then and but it was in
my mind and by the four times like you
know what [ __ ] it
okay make me a free video show me here
we are now he's the [ __ ] the word
that people you like people literally
say literally a [ __ ] burbs literally
people like that my dear ox name is Rick
you know Doc's enemy it's real and and
you know what I said this at a time to
the raucous I mean you're gonna impact
people like you know awesome it is for
people that love to do it to do it you
me people wanted to make documentaries
their whole lives yet only 74 people a
year get to do them and now 74 thousand
people you get to do it all it takes is
one person there's only there's only two
ways to do it either force your way
through and incrementally get better
over time by deploying patience or you
outsource it you're more than welcome to
give up 20% of your business to the most
charismatic friend you know that you
trust you are right you are most people
don't want to give up 20% of their
business you know but I'm like 20
percent of zero is zero
see and if you're not gonna be able to
network and that's important then what
the [ __ ] are we talking about here right
[Music]
I I like results that's why I went not
how I want the results to happen people
have ideology of how they want it to go
down I just want it to go down
I think one of the biggest mistakes that
so many people in youth make is lack of
patience and not willing to pay their
dues like young man with the new
business like I always hear he hasn't
said it but a lot like Gary I'm not
getting a lot of clients like everyone's
saying no I'm like that's what should be
happening that's right that's what
should be happening with a [ __ ] are you
you just graduated school I don't
[ __ ] trust you that means you love
the process that's the [ __ ] I'm talking
about y'all fun it was free for five
hours a day on Twitter you know hopeful
I am that this is gonna be fun for you
cuz if it's fun you got business coming
if it's Gary told me to do it and you're
doing it but you hate it it's gonna die
people don't like to jump because they
think it hurts to resume crazy crazy I'm
trying to get so many kids out of this
nobody gives a [ __ ] if you were in a
place in six months especially when I
asked you if I'm sitting here you're
like it wasn't right for me I have
enough self-awareness the culture wasn't
right my boss's boss wasn't right and I
knew I could do better and I wanted to
be an environment you've won me over for
leaving in six months not I'm cynical to
you resume jumping is some 1984 [ __ ] so
that's number one and number two some
people don't have the self-confidence of
getting another job if they get fired so
they keep their mouth shut
but you don't have to keep your you
don't to be disrespectful when you talk
that's how I've won hey guys thank you
so much for watching my video on YouTube
I wanted to jump in here at the end
because I'm working on a ridiculously
important project for me and I have a
funny feeling you can help if you drink
wine at all or know anybody that drinks
wine at all please go to empathy wines
calm right now and sign up for a
subscription whether it's a three pack
whether it's a six pack or whether it's
a whole case of each for the year
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year
please sign up for club empathy this
project means the world to me that could
really use your support
you